[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العلوي
منتخب المغرب في تجاوز اسبانيا في ثمن
نهائي كاس العالم والبرتغال في مهمه صعبه
امام سويسرا
الاضراب العام في ايران يدخل يومه الثاني
ومحتاجون يواجهون الاعدام المشاركه في
الاحتجاجات
اوكرانيا تستخدم سلاح المسيرات ردا على
قصف موسكو لمنشات الطاقه يحذر من معارك
دوناتس
وبسبب الخلاف حول جزر بحر اي جي تركيا
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
تفتتم اليوم مواجهات ودور السته عشر
لبطوله كاس العالم في قطر بمباراتين حيث
يخوضوا المغرب وبعد تاهله التاريخي
واحتلاله صداره المجموعه السادسه يخوض
ليلا امتحانا صعبا امام منتخب اسبانيا
فيما تنتظر البرتغال مباراه صعبه امام
منتخب السويسرا على ان يتواجه الفائزين
فئتين المبارتين في دور الثمانيه
يسعى المنتخب المغربي لكتابه تاريخ جديد
خلال مشاركته السادسه في نهائيات كاس
العالم عندما يلتقي المنتخب الاسباني بطل
مونديال 2010 هذه الليله
ويدافع منتخب المغرب عن الحظوظ العربيه
بعد ما بات الممثله الوحيد المتبقي في
منافسات المونديال
وعلى استاد المدينه التعليميه في الدوحه
يتطلعوا اسود الاطلس لتكرار انجازهم عام
86 عندما كانوا اول منتخب عربي وافريقيا
يبلغ ثمن نهائي العرس العالمي قبل ان
يخرجوا على يد المانيا الغربيه حينها بهدف
في اللحظات الاخيره هذه المره يطمح
المنتخب المغربي الى تحقيق ما فشل فيه
الجيل الذهبي بقياده محمد التيمومي
والعزيز بودرباله والى كتابه تاريخ جديد
ببلوغ دور ربع النهائي للمره الاولى
وتكراري انجاز الكاميرون والسنغال وغانا
90 و2002 و2010 تواليا وقد افتتح منتخب
اسود الاطلس بقياده المدرب وليد الركراك
مشواره في المجموعه بالتعادل من دون اهداف
مع منتخب كرواتيا وصيف المونديال الماضي
قبل ان يحقق انتصارا تاريخيا بهدفين
نظيفين على بلجيكا المصنفه ثانيا عالميا
قبل تاكيد جدارته بالفوز بهدفين مقابل هدف
وحيد على كندا
وقد اكد الركراكي ان منتخب المغرب سيدخل
المواجهه مع اسبانيا من دون اي ضغوط ومن
اجل اقتناص ورقه الترشح لدور الثمانيه رغم
اعترافه بصعوبه المواجهه حيث يمتلك
المنتخب الاسباني قدرات عاليه على
المستويين الفردي والجماعي وهو قادر على
امتلاك الكره بشكل كبير
وقال ركراكيه الذي اصبح اول مدرب محليا
يقود احد المنتخبات العربيه لبلوغ الادوار
الاقصائيه بكاس العالم قال ان اسود الاطلس
سيخذون المواجهات دون اي عقد مضيفا ان
المغرب عازمزم على بلوغ دور الثمانيه
على كل المزيد من الدوحه معي بالمزيد من
المتابعه من الدوحه موفد العربيه ليث
بازاري ومن الرباط ينضم اليه مراسل
العربيه عدل الزبير ابدا معك ليث كيف هي
الاجواء من عندك واخر التوقعات لموقعات
المغرب اسبانيا ليلا
نعم طالب
الاطلس للفوز في هذه المباراه التي ستقام
بعد اقل من ساعه من خلفي في استاد المدينه
التعليميه ايديكيشن سيتي وهنا شباب مغاربه
يعني اليوم الدوحه احمر واخضر من الصباح
حتى هذه الساعه قبل المباراه
شو عندكم كمان هدى
ماشي مغربي
حضرتك من وين هذا مين فاز من هذا المغرب
من مدينه فاس انا نقاط هنا
وانا
من المغرب
اذا اخذنا الكاميرا لفتتني الشغله قبل شوي
هناك شاب مغربي اتى على دراجه تخيل على
دراجه هوائيه همم للوصول الى هنالك تشجيع
المنتخب المغربي هذه الدراجه
الشاب طبعا هذه امور المباشر الذي يحصل
معنا هذه الدراجه وهو ذهب ينتقد صور امام
الملعب تخيل انه شحن دراشته من المغرب
كازابلانكا من الدار البيضاء الى اسطنبول
ومن ثم على متني
هذه الدراجه انتقل اسطنبول الى هنا هذا
الشاب وصل
عليكم السلام شو اسمك السلام عليكم اسمي
صلاح الدين بن نارين
بتيجي على دراجه كانت صعب الرحله ولا لا
همم صراحه رحله كان صعبه يعني كما قلت لك
كما اقول لك انطلقش من تركيا وبالضبط من
اسطنبول وتوجهت نحو الاردن والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه والان انا في تونس قطر
الخير وبعد قطر ان شاء الله يعني هناك
رحله الى مكه
روحي الى افريقيا او امشي نحو اسيا بس انت
خططت لتكون مش بالمونديال بهذه الفتره
توصل هنا الى الدوحه ولا جاءت الصدف انك
وصلت وقت الموضوع يعني انا ضليت سنه ونصف
وانا احضر لهذه الرحله يعني مش فقط يعني
في التاريخ لا هي كانت
مخطط لها همم مره يسمن همم عديمه تجارب
لكي اكون جاهز في هذه الرحله كان هناك
تحضير بدني تحضير جسدي تحضير مادي والحمد
لله بعد كل هذه المسير انا هنا في قطر نعم
اذا شاهدنا الدراجه طالب اذا سمعت هذه
دراجه الشعب كما نشاهد يحمل اشياء قليل لا
يوجد الكثير من امتعه مع الدراجه التي هل
كانت هذه ما تحمل هنا كافر الوصول هنا الى
الماضيه نعم همم
الاوزان يسمى تقريبا البيت لكن هو يعني
هنا بين
حاولت ان اقود همم اخذ همم
يعني
ههه
عن جد رحله فظيعه ولكن اذا تشاهدنا حامل
انت تذكره معك بطاقه لحضور المباراه بين
المغرب واسبانيا بعد قليل يعني الشهر عند
الشاب طالب يقدر يوصل هل اشتريت التذاكر
هل اشتريت هذه التذكره قبل ما تاتي او
تخطط همم ما تخطط لا لانك صار لك سنه ونصف
بتخططها ما اشتريت هذه التذكره
همم الثلاثه الاولى ولما همم يعني اخذ مر
الى الدور ثمن نهائي حصلت على هذا التذكره
التذكره عندي سؤال فطوري وراح يكون الاخير
هلا لما بدك تفوت على الملعب تحضر
المباراه شو راح تعمل بهالدرجه ثمينه لا
انت بدونها ما بتقدر تتنقل همم صراحه لما
افوت امشي اودعها هنا في مكان همم
الدراجات الان يعني قطر دوله امنه يعني
نزل دراجتك حتى ولو تمسكها مع اي مكان
يعني ولا هذه يقرب يعني الحمد لله السؤال
الاخير شو اكثر صعوبه واجهتك بالرحله من
اسطنبول الى هنا
صراحه لكن كانت صعوبه يعني انا لما عرفت
نفسي انني وصلت بمرض همم
يعني همم
برده نفسانيا كثير لاني كنت عارف بانني
سوف امر من اصعب التجارب في الطريقه وكانت
الرحله من اسطنبول هنا على ظهر على علامات
الدراجه ولا كانت احيانا يجب عليك ان
تضعها في حافل او سياره صراحه عشان همم
كانت هي على الدراجه ولكن لما وصلت الى
حدود سوريا التركيه همم انغلق الباب للاسف
قبل يومين من وصوله فاضطريت الرجوع الى
انقره يعني اطول من المسافه
السوريه كلها
الى عمان هذا هو مش انا الوحيد يعني كل
الرحاله اللي كان الطريق كلهم يعني
استعملوا نفس الشيء شكرا طيب همم
كل الثمانيات بالتوفيق بطبيعه الحال
للمنتخب المغربي الليله الجماهير العربيه
همم في الدوحه كلها المغرب الليله همم
ولكن ماذا سيكون لمنتخب اسبانيا مشجعين
داخل الملعب قياسا بال- بالم 40 المغاربه
همم خصوصا والمشجعين العرب عموما
سؤال كثير محرجه
اسباني ولكن شاهدت كثير ما ننسى انه هذا
الفوز ليس فقط العرب الافارقه هم جزء من
هذا الفوز لا يوجد منتخبات افريقيه الان
والمغرب تقع في القاره الافريقيه اذان
النجاح راح يكون دبل النجاح عربي اذا فاز
المغرب في هذه المباراه هنا في المدينه
التعليميه وسيكون ايضا النجاح افريقي كذلك
واذا شاهدنا اخذنا الكاميرا ما بعرف ادى
عندنا وائل طالب الجماهير ما زال تتواجد
المباراه بعد 45 دقيقه من الان ولكن
الحشود الحشود طيب همم الشباب همم
المغرب يعني كفات شكرا لك لايت مزاري كنت
معنا من الدوحه بالطبع اللي انا عوده اليك
في سياق النشرات اللاحقه لمتابعه نتيجه
هذه المباراه
الان همم مراسل العربيه من الرباط عادل
الزبير انضم الينا عادل اهلا وسهلا بك مع
تمنياتنا بطبيعه الحال بفوز المنتخب
المغربي بهذه الليله كيف يتابع اهل المغرب
هذا الحدث الليله وهل ستكون المهمه الصعبه
ام سهله برايهم
مرحبا طالب الجماهير المغربيه الان تفكر
بقلبها وبعواطفها وتريد انتصارا تاريخيا
مغربيا باسم المغاربه والعرب والافارقه
تريد انجازا تاريخيا جديدا من اسود الاطلس
ببلوغ الربع لاول مره في تاريخ هذا
المنتخب المغربي يتوفر بحسب النقاد
الرياضيين وبحسب الشارع الرياضي المغربي
على منتخب تاريخ استثنائي بامكانه صناعه
المزيد من افراح المغاربه المغاربه الان
تتوقف حياتهم جميعا من اجل ان يتحولوا الى
تتبع المباراه والتشجيع المقاهي المطاعم
الساحات كل الاماكن الممكن ان تتحول الى
اماكن الفرجه المغاربه تجمع فيها هنا من
خلف هذا المقهى يعني اصبح مقتظا بالجماهير
نساء ورجال الشباب الكل يريد اليوم ان
ياتي لمنتخب المغرب طبعا المباراه صعبه
وصعبه جدا منتخب اسبانيا بطل العالم في
جنوب افريقيا 2010 لديه نجوم كبار لكن حتى
الضعف المنتخب الاسباني هي حارس المرمى
وهي خط الدفاع طبعا الجمهور المغربي هنا
في الرباط يقول اذا لعب وليد الرجراجي
بخطه مباراه بلجيكا سوف يفوز المغرب واذا
فتح المباراه وهذا ما يريد المنتخب
الاسباني ستكون المهمه صعبه نعم الطالب
طيب همم نعادل في حال الفوز وهذا همم ما
نتمناه ويتمناه كل العرب الليله المنتخب
المغربي في حال الفوز هل تم تحضيرات معينه
لفعاليات همم احتفاليه في الرباط وفي
المدن المغربيه املا القيمون على ذلك لا
يتحدثون بهذه المساله يتركونها مفاجاه
طالب همم الاعراف المغربيه او التقاليد
المغربيه في تشجيع المنتخب المغربي هو
خروج جماعي عفوي طبيعي للمغاربه الى
الساحات الملتقيات الشوارع قلب العاصمه
وفي كل المدن يخرجون بشكل جماعي وعفو
ويعودون حتى ان ما تسمى في كره القدم
بالفانزول او مناطق المشجعين لا توجد الا
منطقه واحده قامت بها احد الشركات
التجاريه المغربيه في مدينه كازابلانكا
الدار البيضاء باقي المغارب يشجعون في
المنازل في المقاهي في المطاعم هنالك نوع
من التلقائيه طبعا ما بعد ربع النهائي
ستكون هنالك كلمه اخرى ومن الممكن ان تكون
هنالك فعاليات لكن كما شاهدنا لما تاهل
المنتخب المغربي المغاربه خرجوا بمئات
الالاف في كل المدن خرجوا بطريقه عفويه
تلقائيه هدفه شجعوا وتحمس وغادروا هنا في
هذه المقهى من خلفي الناس يخرجون الى اقرب
نقطه للتشجيع والتعبير عن حماسيه ثم
يعودون الى بيوتهم ممتازه
الرباط مراسل العربيه عادل الزبير شكرا
جزيلا لك يا عادل وتمنياتنا بطبيعه الحال
بالتوفيق للمنتخبات المغربيه هذه الليله
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
متى تهدد بحذف الاخبار من فيسبوك اذا اقر
الكونجرس الامريكي مشروع قانون للاعلام
الجزر
موطن الحضارات العريقه
باسرارها العتيقه اساطير مضت منذ الاف
السنين
لكننا نعيش الان عصرا جديدا
لنسرد قصه جديده
[موسيقى]
الافاعي
الاحمر بمياه الصافيه
تنسجم فيها الفخامه مع الطبيعه وتساهم في
حقها وكل لحظه فيها تجسد الهام جديدا
ليكشف النقابه عن عالم جديد
[موسيقى]
جزيره
ستكون فيها انت بطل قصتك
كن جزءا من الاسطوره سندريلا
[موسيقى]
في نجد الاحباب
على بحر الشرقيه
من ريح الهبوب الشماليه ولبن المراعي
اطعام المميز حاضر معنا فيك الجمعه الحلوه
[موسيقى]
بنيناها معكم يوم بعد يوم
بنيناها بالتربيه الصح
في مزارع بالمعايير الاصح
لجاج اليوم
قبل ان يستريح العالم بعد جائحه قالت
البشريه جمعاء تفجرت ازمات جديده ولكن هذه
المره على مستوى العالمي
كم من هائل من الاحداث والمعلومات يتدفق
كل يوم اخبار حروب وتداعيات سياسيه
واقتصاديه اصبح ما بين السطور اكثر من
السطور
اسلوبا جديده
[موسيقى]
لا تتنازل ولا ترضى بشيء عادي لكن المراعي
اجود زبادي مع زبادي المراعي كالاكل الف
[موسيقى]
اهلا اهلا
اليوم الثاني على التوالي ضمن الاحتجاجات
المستمره في البلاد منذ مقتل الفتاه
الكرديه منتصف سبتمبر الماضي على يدي قوات
الامن
هذا وبدا اضراب عام امس ولمده ثلاثه ايام
حيث وثقت الصور اغلاق التجار والباعه في
عشرات المدن الايرانيه ابواب محالين
واضرب نحو 500 من عمال العقود العاملين في
شركه خزانات بيتر كيمياويات في جنوب غرب
ايران كما وصلت طلاب الجامعات الاضراب
تمديدا بقمع قوات الامن للاحتجاجات
[موسيقى]
خلاص
قال النائب مدير وكاله الانباء الايرانيه
فارس المقربه من السلطات عباس درويش
الاخبار وذكر التلفزيون الايرانيه ان
الاخير لا يزال رهن الاحتجاز للتحقيق معه
في اسباب نشر اخبار المضلله
واشارت وكاله فارس في ال 26 من نوفمبر
الماضي الى تعطل موقعها الالكتروني بعد ما
وصفته بعمليه قرصنه وهجوم الكترونيه
ولاحقا اعتقلت السلطات الايرانيه نائبه
مدير الوكاله
في هذه الاثناء اصدرت محكمه ايرانيه احكام
بالاعدام بحق خمسه اشخاص بتريعه قتل احد
افراد قوه الفسيخ وذكر متحدثين باسم
القضاء الايراني ان 11 شخصا اخرين بينهم
ثلاثه اطفال حكم عليهم بالسجن لمدد طويله
في القضيه ذاتها
ومع تصاعد الاحتجاجات والاضطرابات قالت
صحيفه غولسترول جورنال ان السلطات
الايرانيه تنظر في امكانيه تخفيف بعض
القيود المفروض على النساء في خطوه هدفها
امتصاص الغضب المحتاجين
التظاهرات تتواصل وسلطات الايرانيه ترد
تصعيد يفاجئ النظام الباحث عن مخرج ولو
بكي نفسه
مجبرا ينظر النظام في امكانيه تخفيف بعض
القيود على النساء
الاخيره على خطط لاصلاح انفاذ القوانين
المتعلقه بملابس النساء
لكن ثبت اسئله كثيره مطروحه حول تلك
توجهات لا سيما في مدى جديه النظام على
التغيير والى اين يمكن ان يذهب لا تفاصيل
حول الاصلاحات المجمعه غير ان ما رشح ياشي
بتغليظ الغرامات الماليه وتخفيف من
الاحتجاز والاستجواب
محاولات تبدو حظوظ نجاحها على الارض غير
مضمونه فالاحتجاجات مستمره والاضطرابات
تتوالى حتى ان القرار الاخير بحل شرطه
الاخلاق لم يكن كافيا ولا مقنعا
للمتظاهرين
توجههم مشكوك فيه خصوصا في ما يمس اسس
عقائديه يقوم عليها النظام اصلا وهو ما
بدا واضحا في كلام الرئيس الايراني اسس
الجمهوريه راسخه في الدستور اما المورونه
في وسائل تطبيقه كما يقول وهي وسائل لا
يثق بها المحتجون اساسا
اعلن احاكم دونيسكا الموال الى روسيا مقتل
سته على الاقل في القصف الاوكرانيه
المستمره على دمشق اليوم وكان مراسل
العربيه قد اكد ان اوكرانيا استهدف
الدونتس ب 10 صواريخ من نوع جراند مشيرا
الى ان القصف ما يزال مستمر
الكثير من المباني
باشا
اكثر صعوبه وبكلفه عاليه لكن هناك شيء لا
يزال على حاله صلب كالحديد هو الشجاعه
والاراده وبالتالي فان حريتنا لا تقهر
واستقلالنا هو انتصاركم
قبل ذلك علينا
وسيطر عسكريه بصواريخ
استهدفت مجمعات صناعيه عسكريه
بهدف تدمير الامكانات الدفاعيه الاوكرانيه
الروسيه تتخذ كافه الاجراءات لضمان سلامه
النوويه في مواجهه ما وصفه بالارهاب
النووي الاوكراني
لذلك فقد اندلع حريق في مطار منطقه كورس
جنوب روسيا على الحدود مع اوكرانيا حسبما
ما افاد حاكم المنطقه موضحا ان الطائره
مسيره قصفت المطار ما ادى الى اشتعال
النار في صهريج تخزين الوقود ووقع الحريق
بعد يوم من تحميل المسؤوليه عن شني هجوم
بطائرات مسيره على قاعدتين جويتين في عنق
روسيا مع شنها ضربات صاروخيه اخرى على
الاراضي الاوكراني
هذا واظهرت الصور تضرر الى قاعده انجز
الجويه الروسيه جراءه هجوم بطائرات مسيره
استهدف ايضا منشات ريازان العسكري وقد
حملت روسيا كما ذكرنا السلطات الاوكرانيه
المسؤوليه عن الهجوم ووصفته بالارهاب
[موسيقى]
وتحاول اوكراني اصلحه من الطاقه التي
تضررت بعد ما استهدفت بوابه من الصواريخ
الروسيه وذلك من اجل اعاده التامين
الكهرباء والمياه للسكان الذين يعانون من
درجات الحراره من جانبه اكد
نصف المناطق المحيطه بالعاصمه الاوكرانيه
ستظل بدون كهرباء خلال الايام المقبله بعد
الضربات الصاروخيه الروسيه على المنشئه
وقد تعرضت مناطق اخرى في الجنوب والجنوب
الشرقي الى اضرار كبيره
والروسيه ما ادى الى انقطاع الكهرباء
والماء عن السكر
الكياب لمزيد من المتابع ينضم اليهم هناك
مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل حذيفه اهلا
وسهلا بك جديد المشهد الميداني واخر اخبار
القصف تحديدا العاصمه وضواحيها
مع تحياتي طالب يعني العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف تعرضت لقصف بعد عدد من الصواريخ مثل
بقيه المدن طبعا اطلق الروس حوالي 70
الصاروخا لاستطاعه القوات الجويه
ان همم تسقط 60 صاروخ من اصل 70 همم طبعا
همم تم استهداف البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
نتيجه ذلك العاصمه كيف
ولايه بشكل عام 40% من هذه الولايه الان
خارج تغطيه شبكه الكهرباء في العاصمه كيف
كذلك من اخرى طبعا بالنسبه بشكل كبير كذلك
اليسا تضررت بشكل كبير الان المواطنين
يعيشون دون مئه وكهرباء في كثير من احياء
قصه كذلك منطقه همم روج طبعا فينيس يتضرر
بشكل همم
عاده تيار الكهربائي ولكن الان عمليه
القطوعات يعني فعليا همم الان تم الاعلان
في منطقه سوريا وفي منطقه خارقه وفي كييف
وفي او لسه والدره بتروس عندنا جداول
المعتمده للقطوعات هي غير فعاله وانه سوف
يتم قطع التيار الكهربائي
بنظام الطوارئ لان اا القطوعات ستزيد قد
تكون اكثر من مره مرتين او ثلاثه وقد تزيد
عدد ساعات الخطوات هذا فيما يخص طبعا
الاستهداف البنيه التحتيه حذيفه الستراضا
لما تقول يعني اليكسيبوليبا او
اليكسيوليبا حاكم قال ان نصف المناطق
المحيطه بالعاصمه الاوكرانيه
ستظل بلا كهرباء ولا تدفئه الى اجل غير
محدد طب السؤال كيف يصرف الاوكرانيون
الساكنون في هذه المناطق امورهم همم سواء
على مستوى والكهرباء على مستوى التدفئه
همم ما هي البدائل التي يستخدمونها خصوصا
مع تدني درجات الحراره بهذا الشكل
نعم طبعا كثير من هذه المناطق هي بلده
طبعا هو يتحدث عن الولايه بشكل عام وليس
عن المدينه العاصمه اكيد فقط كثير من هذه
المناطق هي بلدات اغلبيه المباني فيها هي
مباني ريفيه قديمه تعتمد على نظام التدفئه
طبعا هي تعتمد في الوقت الحالي على نظام
التدفئه بالكهرباء ولكن لديها نظام تدفئه
تقليدي في هذه المنازل يعمل بالحطب هذا من
جانب من جانب اخر طبعا هناك مناطق او
مباني متعدده الطوابق مثل الشقه وهم
يعيشون دون كهرباء ليس لديهم ابدا احيانا
يعتمدون طبعا اذا كان يوجد غاز في المنزل
فيعتمدون على الغاز هنالك من يقومون
بتشغيل الغاز في المنزل لتدفئه همم المنزل
وهناك من يقومون بتسخين المياه ووضعها في
همم يعني قوارير ووضعها في الفراش او همم
بالقرب منهم حتى تقوم باستخدمون وسائل
تقليديه همم جدا همم يعني همم الخروج من
هذا المازق طبعا الشتاء ودرجات الحراره
خفضه وايضا طبعا همم مباشره عندما يكون
هنالك القطاع في الكهرباء تكون هناك
انقطاع في المياه فالمعاناه تتضاعف يعني
بعدم وجود المياه لذلك عليه ان يقوم
بتعبئه المياه والذهاب يعني امتار لتعبئه
المياه لاستخدامها من كيف مراسل العربيه
حذيفه عادل شكرا جزيلا لك حذيفه على كل
هذه المتابعه
نقل الصحيفه طول ستريت جورنال عن مسؤولين
امريكيين قولهم ان واشنطن عدلت سرا راجمات
صواريخ هيمارس التي قدمتها لاوكرانيا
واضافت الصحيفه ان هذا القرار جاء للحد من
مخاطر اندلاع حرب اوسع مع موسكو
واضاف المسؤولون ان البنت تكون عدل راجمات
هيمارس بحيث لا يمكنها اطلاق صواريخ بعيده
المدى بما في ذلك الصواريخ التي يبلغ
مداها حوالين 200 ميل
وتقول الصحيفه ان هذه التعديلات التي لم
يكشف عنها سابقا تعكس مخاوي فلد الاداره
الامريكيه من عدم وفاء اوكرانيا بوعودها
بعدم ضرب الاراضي الروسيه باسلحه امريكيه
واشنطن كان قد زودت منذ يونيون الماضي
القوات الاوكرانيه ب 20 راجمه صواريخهموس
بمخزون كبير من الصواريخ الموجهه بالاقمار
الاصطناعيه التي يصل مداها الى اكثر من 80
كيلو متر
الداخل الروسي لم يعد بعيدا عن تداعيات
الحرب الجاريه في اوكرانيا حتى القواعد
العسكريه الروسيه لم تعد بعيده عن استهداف
الاوكرانيين الذين غيروا في الاونه
الاخيره من مسار المعارك على الارض
مسؤول اوكراني اكد ان كيف استهدفت قاعدتين
روسيتين جويتين تبعدان مئات الاميال عن
الحدود الاوكرانيه باستخدام طائرات بدون
طيار
المسيرات اطلقت من داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه واستهدفت القائدتين العسكريتين
بمساعده قوات خاصه قريبه من المكان
اعتذر عن هذا الخطا من باريس ينضم اليه
لمزيد من المتابعه همم المحلل العسكريه
عبد الناصر العيد استاذ عبد الناصر اهلا
وسهلا بك برايك كيف سترد موسكو على قصف
مطارات عسكريه لها في العمق الروسي
بمسيرات اوكرانيه وهذا الحدث هل سيدخل
الحرب في مرحله جدي جديده برايك واي مرحله
تحياتي استاذ طالب همم
نقطه الرد يعني الرد الروسي لن يكون مثلا
به هجوم بريه الان لا تستطيع القوات
الروسيه همم شان هجمات بريه واسعه النطاق
بسبب الغطاء الثلجي وبسبب الوحوش يعني همم
اوكرانيا بلد يعني بالشتاء يصبح منطقه
محله لانه سهليه واراضي الزراعيه همم
بالنسبه لهذا التطور وماذا خطورته الحقيقه
يعني همم طبعا انه التطور بحد ذاته لانه
يعني الاوكران اعتمدوا الاسلوب الذي يعني
همم عمل به الروس في الفتره الماضيه
واستخدام الطائرات المسيره جزء منها
مستورد من ايران ل همم يعني لضرب اهداف في
العمق الاوكراني بتاكلوا فراخيصه وبدون
خطوره تذكر همم عكس الايه الان واستخدمه
هذا الطائرات همم
المساله تبدا من عند هل هذه الطائرات غير
بها قدمها حرف الناتو ام هي اوكرانيه همم
الحقيقه مبهم الامر حتى الان همم اوكرانيا
لم تعلن لم تتبنى هذه الضربات لكن منذ
فتره همم
حوالي شهر همم
شركه الصناعات الحربيه الاخرانيه اعلنت
على حسابي على الفيسبوك عن عن يعني نشرت
صور لطائره همم يبلغ مداها حوالي 1000
كيلو متر وقالوا ان هذه طائره اوكرانيه
بالكامل ستدخل الخدمه الخدمه في القريه
يعني
تتمكن هذه المسيارات من تخطي كل الدفاعات
الجويه الروسيه المتطوره يعني عم نحكي
اسئله 400 500 وبعدين
ما الذي يعنيه ذلك
اولا يعني امتلاك طائرات ذات مدى بعيد
يعني المسافه التي قطعتها تقطع بالطائرات
الدرون العاديه المتداوله في اوكرانيا
وكما قلت الطائره التي اعلنت عنها شركه
الصناعات الحربيه الاوكرانيه قالوا ان
مداها 1000 كم وهذا يعني انه اهداف يعني
لا حسره لها داخل الاراضي الروسيه ستكون
في مرمى الاهداف بالنسبه لمساله يعني عدم
تصدي الدفاعات الروسيه لهذه لهذه الطائره
بالطبعه يعني طائرات الدرون عم تمر من من
دفاعات متطوره اكثر من الدفاعات ال- همم
الروسيه دفاعات الروسيه ليست يعني
بالتطور الذي هم يعني يعلنون عنه في بعض
المناطق في بعض المواقع نعم لكن
عندما ننظر الى جبهه بالتساعد الجبهه
الروسيه لا يمكن للدفاعات الروسيه
الحدث لافتت ومهم وخطير يعني القاعده التي
تم استهدافها هي قاعده منذ الحق بس
الثلاثيه ماركه قائد رئيسيه للطائرات
الاستراتيجيه السوفياتيه كانت الان
الروسيه طيب حامله للسلاح النووي هي مقر
طائرات التوبوليف وبالتالي قصف طائرات
التمويل في ال- ال- يعني اللي هي كانت عم
تقصف اوكرانيا بالفتره الماضيه بالصواريخ
بعد المدى ذو دلاله كبيره جدا واعتقد انه
هو قرار اوكراني ولا ولا اظن انه ال- ال-
الدول الغربيه يعني سمحت اوافقت على هذه
الخطوات من باريس المحلل العسكري عبد
الناصر العايد شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ عبد
الناصر على هذه المشاركه
هذا وايد رئاسه الروسيه الدعوات الى
التوصل لسلام طويل مع اوكرانيا وقال
المتحدث باسم الكرم دي متر سكول انه يؤيده
دعوه وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه بشان السلام
في اوكرانيا لكنه اكد على عدم وجود اي
مؤشرات او فرص للحوار
واضاف انه سيتعين ان تحقق روسيا اهداف
عملياتها العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
اولا قبل اجراء محادثات مع اي شركاء محتمل
تيجي
هو حدثنا جميع التدابير لضمان سلامه محطه
النوويه لكن نظام كيا بيصر على التهديد
بحدوث كارثه النوويه من خلال الاستمرار في
قصف المحطه عمدا في الاسبوعين الماضيين
اطلقت القوات الاوكرانيه 33 قذيفه باتجاه
محطه زبرجيا انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه
طردت معظم القذائف لكن العديد منها اصطدم
بمنشات تؤثر على التشغيل الامن لمحطه
الطاقه النوويه
على انها ارهاب النووي
هددت شركه متى مالكه فيسبوك بازاله
الاخبار من قصتها تماما اذا اقر الكونجرس
الامريكي قانون المنافسه والمحافظه على
الصحافه بحجه ان جهات البحث استفادت من
نشر اعلى من استطيع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نشاط الخامسه مستمره في ايضا
منازل سيدني تتحدى ازمات الطاقه وتحتفل
بعيد الميلاد
[موسيقى]
المراعي اجود زبادي مع زبادي المراعي
كالاكل الف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يلا نبي نصحصح نبي الاكل ابداع جهزي العده
وافردي الخبزه وادهن اللبنه والحين وين
العجينه حطي اللبنه والزعتر رشيه ايوه
بالضبط اغرفيها شويه سمان الله والخيار
قطعيه ايوه غمسيه يا سلام عليك يا فنانه
كل فخر صنعت في السعوديه لبنه المراعي
الفاخره طعمها يبيض الوجه
يد الام ياما شاف الطول هالمشوار
ومع هذا لسه بتعرف كيف تختار
حليب المراعي الطازج الفرق بيدين الامهات
[موسيقى]
زياره الرسميه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
تستمر حتى الجمعه وذكرت وكاله الانباء
السعوديه ان الزياره تاتي بناء على دعوه
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
وسيشارك خلالها في قمه سعوديه صينيه
هذا وتشهد القمه السعوديه الصينيه توقيعه
اتفاقيات مبدئيا بين البلدين بقيمه 110
مليارات ريال او ما يعادل نحو 30 مليار
دولار وفقا لوكاله الانباء السعوديه
وذكرت الوكاله ان عدد الاتفاقيات سيصل الى
20 اضافه لتوقيع وثيقه الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه بين السعوديه والصين وكذلك
خطه بين رؤيه المملكه 2030 ومبادره الحزام
والطريق
حدد وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود شاويش
اوغلو اجراءات ضد اليونان اذا وصلت تسريحه
جذورها في بحر ايجي وقالت شاويش ابنه انما
وصفه بانتهاك المستمر للمعاهده سيفتح
سياده هذه الجزر للنقاش ويجبر تركيا على
الدفاع عن حقوقها مشيرا الى ان يجب ان تضل
منزوعه السلاح بما يتماشى مع المعاهدات
الدوليه
عن مناورات عسكريه يونانيه على جزيرتي
رودس في بحري
ينضم اليه من اسطنبول لمزيد من المتابعه
لهذا الموضوع المحلل السياسي جواد جوك سيد
جواد اهلا وسهلا بك هذه التهديدات التي
سمعناها من السيد مولود شاويش اوغلو اليوم
هل هي التهديدات اعتياديه لا تاخر تخرج عن
المالوف المتوتر بين انقره واثناء ام لا
التهديدات اليوم
جديه وخطيره
لا يسمح لهما باشتباكات عسكريه وغير ذلك
بالنسبه الى 12 جزيره اليونان لا يحق لهم
ان همم يعني تبادل عسكري فقط
لكن بشكل عام التوتر بيننا وبين اليونان
دائما موجوده خاصه
قبيل كل الانتخابات سيزيده همم تصريحات
ناريه ضد الاخر نعم
ولكن كيف يمكن لانقرا ان ترد في حال حصلت
هذه المناورات ورات فيها انقر رساله تهديد
تركيا اين تقوم بمناظرات عسكريه
مناورات بحريه خاصه ويعلن الساحل بحريه حر
لها وغير ذلك يعني تصريحات دائما موجوده
لكن بشكل عام لا اظل ان تكون هناك كما قلت
يعني اشتباكات وغير ذلك لكن تركيا اذا
مقابل مواجهه مع هذه تهديدات تقوم
بالمناورات العسكريه بالمناورات قويه جدا
وهنا نقطه المهمه الاساسيه ان تقوم تركيا
بالاتفاقيه مع الجانب المصري وتطبيع
العلاقات مع الجانب المصري هناك بالنتيجه
خلافات لا زالت موجوده لكن دوله مصر هي
المهمه ممكن ان تكون بسيطه بين تركيا
واليونان خاصه بعد اعلان التطبيع بين
الجنه
اليونانيه بالكامل ومن حق اليونان ممارسه
السياده علي هلا سيما اجراء مناورات
عسكريه ولا يعني هم لا ينشرون قوات ولكن
يجرون مناورات ومن حقهم هذه الجزر
اليونانيه
بالنتيجه بتواجد عسكر في هذه الجزر الاثنى
عشر ممنوعه من قبل اتفاقيه باريس سنه
1947 ولهذا السبب يعني
يونان تريد ان تغير
استراتيجياتها وسياستها تجاه تركيا
بالنتيجه الجزر هناك جزيرتين لتركيا ايضا
لا تقوم تركيا بالمناورات العسكريه هناك
همم على همم يعني قريب من اليونان جدا
بدنا نتيجه المنطقه لا تتحمل كما تراث من
الجانبين نتيجه الحكومه التركيه تدعو
للرجوع بين الجانبين
من اسطنبول المحلل السياسي جواد شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه صارت منازل في احياء غربيه من
مدينه سيدني الاستراليه اثارت اعجاب
المارين بانارات وصفت بالمبهره رغم تكاليف
الكهرباء في ازمه طاقه تخيم على البلاد
بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا
جورج وسوف
[موسيقى]
نشاط الخامسه المفصله من العربيه اطيب
التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]